hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the things in the
night we are about to go into the lab to
confront my father mother is dead and I
don't know if my mom is alright father
you will pay for all the lives you've
stolen traitor
bla bla bla bla I'm actually wondering
if this is getting close to the end here
because this isn't the lab I knew I need
to look around holy crap place gigant
I'd like seriously gigantic locked old
archives
alright there might be more to this game
than I suspected yeah
Carrillo and screw you too many of you
way too many of you first door dead guy
very naked
nope I was in the lobby when Astra
walked by and dropped the key to his
office I should have given it back to
him but something was going on so I
thought of sneaking in his office there
I found an old book talking about
raising the dead but at that moment
someone was coming so I tried to take it
with me I wouldn't move it was like a
force was holding it there and because
of that my master found me out and
became furious with me he gave me a look
that scared the hell out of me I was in
the lobby today and I heard screaming in
the hall but suddenly something busted
down the door covered in blood I hide
myself behind the couch and after a few
minutes waiting that thing disappeared
I'm gonna leave the key here and try to
escape I'll try to get some help in town
ah
was that man even this one room was
really welcome I have my old key here
don't know what is for about to run out
of oil again
and I'm actually low on tinder boxes - I
kind of overused him in that one room I
was a little creeped out
yup oh no oh no oh no oh no no no no no
no no I no no
[Music]
No ah no no way no no no no come on not
fair no no oh no no no no
bah gah
No
I think I even get in these
no no no okay
there's nothing in here I need right you
just leave
right no miss
okay I'm leaving
that was the scariest room where nothing
happened at all
I've ever seen in my entire life there
must have been something I missed
I don't know something I missed missed I
mean one of the reason would there be
for this no no no no no okay okay I'm
okay
nope
what was just keep - I don't even
remember firing round still maybe the
game is like not working at the moment
because I went ahead but I don't know
I'm hoping not
okay I'm okay okay that looks really
intricate well done sir guy who made
this game custom story whatever you want
to call it
all right there we go
Oh what's this oh no more stuff it's a
lot more than I thought there would be I
thought it was coming to a close
anything under the stairs back here oh
okay that's gonna wait and there's a lot
of stuff this is not how to lab this a
labyrinth get up there yes no yes no man
this place is you what oh that's locked
but that's the Masters office
I really like that Lightning effect I
don't remember that being in earlier
ones an old book about demonic evil how
to raise the dead
lost ruins from another world the book
was found by one of my servants in the
old archives it talks about ruins that
lie right under this town I can't
believe it all this years I've lived
here without knowing about this I must
read more about this subject everything
is real but I'm not feeling too good
it seemed like someone was talking to be
down there I need to make new soldiers
now that I have a new body they will all
die and I'll take over this world okay
creepy real lab key ha ha
not them Vicki ficky lab keys the real
one I really can't help but feel Oh
okay never mind never mind I was gonna
say I was about to say I can't I can't
help but feel that I might have screwed
something up because of me accidentally
breaking through something like that but
I'm gonna go down here if this is a real
lab I'm not gonna go in it right away
I'm gonna go explore a bit more because
there's a lot of stuff up under the
stairs yes
oh nothing never mind never mind
this is too old house whoa I didn't know
is that guy or that big sword guess I
didn't look at it very closely I'll get
back to it Oh oh wow there's a lot more
than I thought and that is a lot of
blood all right I'll hold off on going
down there because I want to take care
of things first when I fully explore
this area and I feel like the labrie
olap might be in that old house so to
seem logical I'm gonna go look at this
this is crazy man I swear this guy who
made this thought I have nothing but
like respect for what he's done he's
taking strides that other custom
storymakers would never think of them
doing this everything is intricate
gorgeously bill
shouldn't you how to get up there I
think maybe if I take a box up there I
can get up there but I mean wow look at
all this it will not move maybe I have
to open the way from your cell phone
just like stuck in the wall here hands
hey buddy
okay alright then me what I used to love
and you shall pass wow this is so cool
the one that satisfies the three in
payment in Pride shall pass the demon
the victim the father each one of them
is missing something to make them
complete okay so that's the demon that's
probably the victim and that's the
father in the middle maybe not maybe
that's the victim I'm probably a victim
okey-dokey cool ah cool beans very very
cool that is dark Park is so little oil
left why are there so many men's suits
of armor not fair not fun man oh this is
creepy
it's almost worrisome that I haven't
seen a monster in forever oh man oh so
dark I don't want to use my oil though
was this library okay check out the
library I gotta find a bunch of things
apparently hello that's gonna break
break yep I knew it oh I knew it I so
knew it I called that a lot of us okay
yeah whatever take some load on them and
get over yourself such a pansy I'd be
able to take that fall do a quadruple
black flip lows Swan diving down yeah
that would have been no big deal
I'm actually really happy that it's not
going to end soon because I love this
custom story
low frame rates down here I'll tell you
what
[Music]
arrey a little bit better than man
hello what aha right away
such a chinois okay oh man why can't I
get any oil during this nope
Bienvenue that's what I remember that
thing from Justine cannot see a thing
dead guy another one lots of dead guys
ah
crap I don't know what that sound is in
the background but it's gonna get creepy
yeah
huh
seriously how does he make the
environment seem so cool I'm sorry about
the low frame rates guys for some reason
looks like totally dropping everything
for me while I'm in down here
I'm like totally freaking out man
okay all right I'm actually out of time
so I'm just gonna cut it here so thank
you everybody so much for watching my
stare at this because my frame rates are
when I look at this thank you everybody
so much for watching a holy crap this is
getting creepy oh and I will see you in
the next video bye bye